bonjour à tous aujourd'hui on va parler
du paradoxe des jumeaux le paradoxe des
jumeaux c'est un sujet qui a fait couler
beaucoup d'encre il faut dire que c'est
à la fois un des résultats les plus
connus de la théorie de la relativité et
en même temps un des plus mal compris
j'imagine que vous en avez déjà entendu
parler prenez deux jumeaux âgés de 20
ans et imaginer que l'un des deux
embarquent dans une fusée très rapide
disons les deux tiers de la vitesse de
la lumière et mettre le cap vers une
destination lointaine comme proxima du
centaure l'étoile située à 4 années
lumière de nous
une fois arrivés sur place la fusée fait
demi tour et revient sur terre du point
de vue du jus moore rester sur terre
l'aller-retour aura duré douze ans il a
donc 32 ans
mais le jumeau qui a voyagé dans la
fusée lui n'aura vu passer que neuf ans
au moment des retrouvailles
il aura donc seulement 29 ans trois
années de moins que son frère et notez
bien qu'il ne s'agit pas d'un phénomène
biologique de modification du
vieillissement
une horloge à bord de la fusée indiquera
elle aussi que le voyage aller retour
n'aura duré que neuf ans ce résultat
étonnant est un classique en relativité
restreinte et on le résume souvent avec
des expressions un peu ambigu comme
quand on va vite le temps se dilate ou
encore le temps passe plus lentement ou
pire quand on va vite le temps se
ralentit alors outre le fait que le
phénomène paraît déjà difficile à avaler
vous sentez peut-être qu'il ya un
problème avec les formulations de ce
genre qu'est ce que ça peut vouloir dire
que le temps se ralentit quand on va
vite pour faire la lumière sur tout ça
on va voir en détail ce qu'il se passe
dans cette expérience de pensée
pourquoi certains ont cru qu'il
s'agissait d'un paradoxe est pourquoi en
définitive il n'y a rien de paradoxal
[Musique]
pour commencer voyons rapidement les
principes de base de la relativité
restreinte alors je ne vais pas tout
détailler j'ai déjà fait une vidéo assez
complète sur le sujet mais on va voir
l'essentiel
une des idées centrales de cette théorie
c'est quand relativité restreinte le
temps et l'espace ne sont plus deux
concepts distincts et indépendant ils
sont beaucoup plus entremêlées que dans
la physique de newton et galilée celle
qu'on apprend au lycée en relativité
on considère la notion d'espace-temps et
on représente souvent cela de cette
manière il y à la dimension de temps et
les dimensions des espaces alors pour
des raisons pratiques on va représenter
aujourd'hui qu'une seule dimension des
ce passe comme si on vivait sur une
droite au lieu d'un espace à trois
dimensions avec cette représentation
l'espace-temps n'a que deux dimensions
mais vous allez voir que ça va nous
suffire un point de l'espace temps par
exemple celui ci on appelle cela un
événement bah oui un événement ça se
produit à un endroit précis à un moment
précis
c'est donc un point de l'espace temps
par exemple si je frappe dans mes mains
c'est un événement pareil si je décide
d'ouvrir une bouteille de champagne
ce sont des points précis de l'espace
temps pour se repérer dans l'espace
temps c'est comme pour se repérer dans
l'espace
ces pratiques de pouvoir utiliser des
coordonnées si vous jouez à la bataille
navale vous vous repérer grâce à une
grille qui permet de localiser les
positions si vous prenez la surface de
la terre vous pouvez y repérer n'importe
quel lieu grâce à la latitude et la
longitude cgri constituent ce qu'on
appelle un système de coordonnées et
biens dans l'espace temps c'est pareil
pour repérer les événements et pour
pouvoir leur attribuer des nombres on a
besoin d'un système de coordonnées alors
en théorie on peut imaginer plein de
façons de le faire mais il y en a une
qui est assez naturel c'est d'utiliser
ce qu'on appelle un référentiel imaginé
pour commencer que vous ayez simplement
besoin de repérer des positions autour
de vous dans l'espace
une manière de procéder ce serait de
vous trimballer avec une grille rigide
tout autour de vous munis de graduation
et de l'utiliser pour mesurer les
positions des choses qui vous entourent
maintenant si en plus en chaque point de
cette grille vous attacher une horloge
cela va vous permettre précisément
d'attribuer des coordonnées à n'importe
quel événement de l'espace temps si un
événement se produit vous regardez
enquête
la grille il a eu lieu et le temps qu
indique l'horloge située à cet endroit à
ce moment là puisque cela permet de
mettre des coordonnées d'espace-temps à
chaque événement un référentiel de ce
genre constitué d'une grille spatiale et
d'horloges en chaque point
eh bien on peut le voir comme une grille
de l'espace temps et c'est cette
représentation qu'on utilisera dans la
suite
à noter bien qu'un référentiel c'est en
fait une constructions abstraites qu'on
peut considérer comme un fini il existe
partout à la fois et ça permet de
mesurer des événements même si tu es
très loin du point d'origine d'ailleurs
même si on imagine souvent le
référentiel comme lié à un objet
physique auquel seraient attachées cette
grille en fait on n'en a pas vraiment
besoin des référentiels deux jours pour
se repérer dans l'espace temps on peut
en imaginer plein ils peuvent notamment
être décalés ou en mouvement les uns par
rapport aux autres mais la théorie de la
relativité restreinte nous spécifie deux
choses importantes
la première c'est qu'il existe des
référentiels particulier privilégié
qu'on appelle les référentiels
inertielle ce sont les référentiels dans
lesquelles les objets qu'ils ne
subissent aucune force sont immobiles
bien vous en ligne droite à vitesse
constante
ce qu'on appelle la fameuse translation
rectiligne uniforme et justement si vous
prenez deux référentiels inertielle ils
seront toujours forcément en translation
rectiligne uniforme
l'un par rapport à l'autre cette idée
qu'il existe des référentiels inertielle
qui serait spéciaux en quelque sorte
elle n'est pas spécifique de la
relativité restreinte
on utilisait déjà ces référentiels pour
la relativité au sens de galilée on les
appelait d'ailleurs souvent les
référentiel galiléen mais ce qui change
en relativité restreinte
c'est que dans tous ces référentiels
inertielle la lumière va à la même
vitesse la vitesse de la lumière est
constante absolue est indépendante du
référentiel inertielle alors ça à la
base c'est une observation un truc qu'on
a constaté expérimentalement et c'est
quelque chose d'impossible à intégrer
dans la physique de newton égalité et 7
à cause de ça qu'il a fallu créer la
relativité restreinte en particulier
pour satisfaire ce caractère absolu de
la vitesse de la lumière il a fallu
abandonner des principes qui nous
étaient très naturelle et intuitif ainsi
par exemple en relativité restreinte les
durées mesuré ne sont plus absolu si
vous prenez deux événements de
l'espace-temps et
vous mesurez l'écart de temps qui les
sépare la valeur obtenue va dépendre du
référentiel dans lequel on a fait la
mesure cette relativité des durées c'est
une idée assez difficile à accepter mais
à mon avis elle a une conséquence encore
plus perturbante en relativité
restreinte
il n'y a plus de notion absolue de
simultanéité vous savez dans notre
intuition quotidienne on parle souvent
du présent par imposition au passé et à
l'avenir
comme si la notion de présent de en ce
moment avait un sens absolu et bien pas
un relativité restreinte se demander ce
qu'il se passe maintenant en ce moment
par exemple sur mars ou pluton et bien
ça n'a pas de sens bien défini on en
reparlera mais pour l'instant revenons à
nos humours pour essayer d'y voir clair
dans ce paradoxe que j'ai évoquée au
début de la vidéo on va réaliser des
diagrammes d'espace-temps représentons
donc notre espace temps avec seulement
deux dimensions et pour pouvoir mettre
des coordonnées aux évènements qui s'y
produisent on va utiliser un référentiel
qu'on présente comme une grille un
quadrillage de l'espace temps on va
imaginer que ce référentiel est celui
attaché à la terre le référentiel
terrestre
ça n'est évidemment pas le seul choix
possible on aurait pu en prendre
d'autres et c'est ce qu'on fera plus
tard un objet qui se déplace dans
l'espace apparaîtra comme une courbe
dans ce diagramme cette courbe traduit
l'évolution de la position de l'objet ou
fur et à mesure que le temps passe on
appelle cela sa ligne d'univers prenons
par exemple le jumeau qui reste sur
terre puisqu'on s'est placé dans le
référentiel terrestre
eh bien il reste tout le temps au même
endroit au fur et à mesure que le temps
passe et sa ligne d'univers et celle ci
de façon générale un objet immobile dans
le référentiel qu'on a choisi sera
toujours représenté par une ligne
d'univers verticale un objet qui va à
vitesse constante dans le référentiel
sera représenté par une droite plus ou
moins inclinés est d'autant plus incliné
que la vitesse est importante alors un
cas particulier ce sont les lignes qui
représentent les trajectoires des rayons
lumineux puisque rien ne peut aller plus
vite qu'un rayon lumineux cela
représente la pente maximum atteignable
par la ligne d'univers d'un objet et
donc pour faire simple on va choisir les
unités du graphique pour que ces lignes
soit à 45 degrés par exemple si on
graduelle axe vertical du temps en année
et l' axe horizontal de l'espace en
d'années lumière
le trajet d'un rayon lumineux partant de
l'origine sera représenté par une
diagonale et enfin pour finir dans un
diagramme de ce genre chaque ligne
horizontale représente une ligne de
simultanéité du référentiel
il s'agit de l'ensemble des événements
qui ont lieu simultanément au même
moment dans le référentiel considéré
détail important se ne sont pas des
lignes d'univers puisque aucun objet
physique ne peut avoir cette trajectoire
elles servent juste à repérer les
moments simultanée de ce référentiel
bien voyons maintenant ce qu'il arrive
au deuxième jumeaux imaginons que le
point d'origine du référentiel
représente l'événement du décollage de
la fusée la séparation des jumeaux pour
celui qui va vers proxima du centaure
aux deux tiers de la vitesse de la
lumière
et bien voici la ligne d'univers qu'on
aura proxima et en a environ quatre
années lumière l'événement qui marque
son arrivée aux abords de l'étoile sera
celui ci dans le référentiel jumeaux
terrestre cela se produira au bout de
six ans
jusqu'ici tout va bien mais on l'a dit
en relativité restreinte
la notion de durée entre deux événements
n'est plus absolu elle dépend du
référentiel
là on a calculé qu entre le décollage et
l'arrivée à proxima il s'était écoulé
six ans dans le référentiel terrestre
mais combien de temps s'est il est coulé
dans le référentiel du deuxième jumeaux
celui de la fusée c'est quelque chose
qu'on peut calculer assez facilement
avec les principes de la relativité
ça n'a rien de très compliqué et pour
ceux que ça intéresse je vous écris
calcul et vous pouvez mettre pause pour
les autres je vous donne la réponse pour
le jumeau de la fusée il ne s'est écoulé
qu'à environ quatre ans et demi pas six
ans souvent pour désigner cette
différence entre les mesures de la durée
qui sépare deux événements on parle de
la dilatation du temps alors le terme
n'est pas idéal et peut mener à des
confusions
alors retenez plutôt qu'il s'agit de la
relativité des durées je répète la durée
qui sépare deux événements dépend du
référentiel ici entre le décollage et
l'arrivée vers proxima six ans dans le
référentiel terrestre quatre ans et demi
dans le référentiel de la fusée
cet effet de la relativité des durées ça
n'est pas un artefact de calcul
il est parfaitement réel et on peut le
mettre en évidence expérimentalement
dans certaines situations on voit très
bien notamment avec des particules qu'on
appelle les murs
les murs ce sont des sortes de cousins
des électrons et ils sont parfois
produit lors des collisions des rayons
cosmiques avec les molécules de
l'atmosphère quand un million et créer
de cette façon ils possèdent
généralement par rapport à l'atmosphère
de la terre une vitesse très proche de
celle de la lumière
en revanche sa durée de vie est très
limité puisque on sait qu'un million se
désintègre systématiquement au bout
d'environ 2 microsecondes
sauf que depuis la surface de la terre
avec nos détecteurs on observe en
permanence des muons qui semble être
resté en vie bien plus longtemps que ça
et avoir fait presque dix fois plus de
chemin alors cela peut paraître étonnant
mais ça s'explique parfaitement avec le
phénomène de relativité des durées dans
le référentiel du mur le temps qui
s'écoule entre les deux événements que
sont sa création et sa désintégration ce
temps c'est seulement 2 microsecondes
mais vu de la terre dans le référentiel
terrestre donc à cause de la vitesse
relative proche de celle de la lumière
la durée qui s'écoule est environ dix
fois plus importante
la durée entre deux événements est
relative
[Musique]
alors reprenons nos jumeaux le premier
vient d'arriver aux abords de proxima du
centaure son horloge de bord indique
quatre ans et demi et il décide de faire
demi-tour pour retourner vers la terre
et là il se passe exactement la même
chose
son voyage retour durera également
quatre ans et demi de son point de vue à
lui et dans le référentiel terrestre
cela sera à nouveau six ans quand les
deux jumeaux se retrouve le jumeau
terrestre aura donc vu défiler 12 ans et
celui de la fusée seulement neuf ans il
aura moins vieilli ils râlent 29 ans
tandis que l'autre en aura 32 alors
formulé comme ça c'est différent et plus
perturbant que mon histoire de lyon ça
n'est pas juste une mesure fait de deux
points de vue différents
là on peut au même endroit au même
moment constaté que l'un des jumeaux a
vieilli moins que l'autre et je répète
un rien à voir avec un phénomène
biologique pour lui il s'est écoulé
moins de temps que pour l'autre et cet
écart de temps dépend de la vitesse de
la fusée plus la fusée va vite plus en
proportion l'écart sera important en
allant à 99 % de la vitesse de la
lumière
le voyage aller retour aurait pris
environ huit ans pour le jumeau
terrestre et seulement un an pour celui
de la fusée c'est super intrigant mais
si on fait une analogie avec les mesures
de distance dans l'espace on peut y voir
un peu plus clair
prenez deux points sur une carte cela ne
vous surprend pas si je vous dis que la
distance qui sépare ces deux points
dépend du chemin choisi pour les relier
il ya des chemins plus court qui ont
moins de kilomètres et d'autres plus
long et il y en a même un qui en
principe est le plus court possible
si on prend deux événements de
l'espace-temps la séparation et les
retrouvailles des jumeaux et qu'on
considère des lignes d'univers qui relie
ces deux événements le temps écoulé le
long d'une ligne d'univers dépend du
chemin suivi cette mesure de temps le
long d'une ligne d'univers c'est un
concept très important de la relativité
qu'on appelle le temps propre à tout
trajectoire dans l'espace temps on peut
associer un temps propre et entre deux
événements donner le temps propres
dépens de la trajectoire suivie et notez
bien on ne peut pas dire que ce soit
parce que le temps se ralentit ou que
les seconds s'allonge
quand un chemin sur une carte est plus
long qu'un autre ça n'est pas que les
kilomètres ils sont plus grands ou que
les routes votre vélo devienne
soudainement plus petit il y a plus de
distance à franchir c'est tout est bien
là de même c'est juste qu'il y en
quelque sorte moins de temps à franchir
pour relier les deux événements par la
ligne d'univers du jumeau de la fusée
que par celle du jumeau terrestre avec
ce raisonnement vous remarquerez quand
même qu'il ya quelque chose de contre
intuitif le chemin qui correspond au
temps le plus court et celui qui paraît
visuellement le plus long dans le
diagramme et réciproquement
et bien c'est parce que le temps c'est
certes une dimension supplémentaire mais
ça n'est pas la même chose que l'espace
est donc ce diagramme d'espace-temps ne
s'interprète pas comme une carte
classique
d'ailleurs pour ceux qui on me pose tout
à l'heure c'est lié au signe - qui
apparaît dans le pseudo théorème de
pythagore bien donc en résumé si on
admet les règles de la relativité
restreinte
cette histoire de jumeaux qui vieillit
moins que l'autre est assez perturbante
mais pas forcément de quoi appeler ça un
paradoxe
d'ailleurs quand cette expérience de
pensée a été imaginé pour la première
fois en 1911 par paul langevin
sur une idée originale d'einstein eh
bien elle n'a pas été présentée comme un
paradoxe
et pourtant il y a un truc bizarre à
première vue on dirait que c'est
vraiment la vitesse que jumeaux de la
fusée qui limite son vieillissement et
plus il ira vite moins il vieillira et
pourtant on sait la vitesse c'est un
truc relatif le jumeau de la terre se
considère comme immobile et vous à la
fusée s'éloigner lui à 200 mille
kilomètres par seconde mais
réciproquement celui de la fusée peut
très bien considérer que c'est lui qui
est immobile et que c'est la terre qui
s'éloigne à 200 mille kilomètres par
seconde
donc du point de vue de la fusée c'est
le jumeau de la terre qui devrait -
vieillir et là c'est très bizarre parce
que si la situation est effectivement
symétrique entre les deux jumeaux
comment est ce que l'un peut vieillir
moins que l'autre il devrait pas y avoir
de différence entre les 2 et 7 ans à que
le paradoxe des jumeaux est un paradoxe
alors cette objection elle avait déjà
été formulée à ses taux dans les années
1920 par des physiciens comme painlevé
où le philosophe henri bergson et
pourtant quand on y regarde de plus près
il n'ya pas de paradoxe car la situation
n'est pas symétrique entre les deux
jumeaux pour vous montrer un petit
rappel en relativité il existe des
référentiels particulier les
référentiels inertielle et ici ce sont
bien des référentiels supposé inertielle
qu'on a utilisées mais il ya une
entourloupe le premier jumeaux
celui qui restait sur terre et dans le
même référentiel inertielle tout au long
de l'expérience
le référentiel de la terre mais le
deuxième jumeaux celui de la fusée doit
faire demi tour au milieu il change de
référentiels en faisant ça ce jumeau et
inertielle sur chacun des deux segments
du voyage mais il n'est pas inertielle
sur l'ensemble de la trajectoire
une autre manière de voir ce changement
de référentiel inertielle c'est de dire
que pour faire son demi tour
la fusée doit subir une décélération
puis une accélération dans l'autre sens
alors que le jumeau terrestre lui ne
subit rien du tout à aucun moment donc
la situation des deux jumeaux n'est pas
symétrique et par conséquent il n'y a
rien de paradoxal a affirmé que l'un
puisse être plus jeune que l'autre lors
des retrouvailles
le point clé de la résolution du
paradoxe c'est quand relativité
restreinte les vitesses sont relatives
on ne peut pas définir deux notions
absolu de vitesse mais on peut définir
une notion absolue d'accélération la
fusée subi vraiment une accélération et
elle a subi dans tous les référentiels
inertielle alors admettons le jumeau de
la fusée va - vieillir que l'autre est
présenté comme ça c'est assez tentant de
dire que c'est du coup plutôt
l'accélération elle même qui est
responsable du phénomène et c'est assez
bizarre parce que du coup on peut se
demander à quel moment l'écart se creuse
vraiment entre les deux jumeaux c'est
juste au moment du demi tour
faisons une très légère variante de
l'expérience de pensée reprenons le
jumeau de la fusée mais imaginons qu'en
faisant son voyage il n'est pas encore
vraiment décidé s'il allait faire demi
tour ou pas il arrive en vue de proxima
et on sait qu'il a mis 4 ans et demi de
son point de vue à us
et pourtant s'il n'a pas encore fait
demi tour mais il est inertielle depuis
le début est donc pour l'instant la
situation est vraiment symétrique
on envie de penser qu'ils devraient
avoir 6 ans comme l'autre donc c'est le
demi tour qu'il fait soudainement
rajeunir et bien pour lever l'ambiguïté
il faut se souvenir d'un truc primordial
en relativité
il n'y a plus de notion absolue de
simultanéité c'est super important
dire que deux événements distincts sont
simultanés c'est relatif aux
référentiels pour matérialiser le truc
imaginons que suite au départ de la
fusée chacun des deux jumeaux ouvre
chaque année une bouteille de champagne
pour marquer l'anniversaire
ça nous fait des événements précis qui
se trouve là sur les lignes d'une
r demandons-nous maintenant ce qu'il se
passe sur terre au moment où la fusée
atteint proxima du centaure du point de
vue du jumeau terrestre c'est facile on
l'a dit les lignes de simultanéité sont
comme ça et donc au moment où la fusée
atteint proxima le jumeau terrestre
ouvre sa sixième bouteille de champagne
très bien maintenant plaçons-nous du
point de vue du jumeau de la fusée quand
il arriva proxima quels sont les
événements qui se trouvent sur sa ligne
de simultanéité ces événements qui pour
lui ont lieu en ce moment et bien la
ligne de simultanéité n'est pas la même
dans ce référentiel la simultanéité est
une notion relative pour trouver les
lignes de simultanéité du référentiel de
la fusée il faut se souvenir d'un truc
la vitesse de la lumière doit être la
même dans tous les référentiels
inertielle avec les unités qu'on a
choisi ça se traduit par le fait que la
ligne de lumière doit diviser en deux
langues entre les deux axes d'espacé et
de temps donc la kz2 temps et les lignes
du simultanéité du jumeau la fusée sont
comme ça et celle qui contient
l'événement de l'arrivée à proxima est
celle ci donc pour le jumeau de la fusée
l'arrivée à proxima se fait au bout de
quatre ans et demi mais de son point de
vue à lui au moment où ça se produit le
jumeau terrestre n'a ouvert que trois
bouteilles de champagne il n'a vécu que
trois ans et quelques et c'est
parfaitement logique un temps que le
demi tour n'a pas eu lieu la situation
doit être symétrique
chacun des deux jumeaux estime dans son
référentiel qu'au moment de l'arrivée à
proxima c'est l'autre qui est plus jeune
mais quand le jumeau de la fusée décide
de faire son nid tour et donc de changer
de référentiel il casse la symétrie dans
nouveau référentiel qui est le sien la
ligne de simultanéité est différente et
sur celle ci le jumeau de la terre a
quasiment neuf ans le changement de
référentiel fait varier instantanément
de presque six ans son estimation de
l'âge de l'autre jumeau le trajet retour
dur ensuite quatre ans et demi pour lui
mais il estime que cela correspond à une
durée de trois ans et quelques seulement
pour les jumeaux terrestre et donc de
façon cohérente
lors des retrouvailles le jumeau
terrestre a bien vécu douze ans alors
que lui seulement 9
alors oui je sais c'est dur à accepter
comme calcul mais tout cela c'est la
faute de notre incapacité à abandonner
ligne
et de simultanéité absolue c'est
vraiment dur de se convaincre que quand
on considère des lieux éloignés
la simultanéité n'a plus de sens absolu
et en particulier quand le jumeau de la
fusée se demande quel âge à mon frère en
ce moment et bien la réponse va changer
soudainement de 6 ans du fait demi tour
qui le place dans un autre référentiel
la conséquence de cela et c'est
primordial c'est que cela n'a pas de
sens absolu de comparer les âges des
deux jumeaux tant qu'on ne les a pas à
nouveau réunies tant qu'ils sont en des
lieux différents
il n'y a pas de notion absolue de
différence d'âge entre eux et de lequel
est plus vieux que l'autre pour les
comparer de façon absolue il faut les
réunir au même point de l'espace temps
au même événement et c'est en cela que
l'expérience de pensée des jumeaux est
un truc conceptuellement plus profond
que ce qu'on appelle la dilatation du
temps et qu'on illustre avec le temps de
vider mieux qu'au smic alors tout ce
raisonnement sur les jumeaux je
l'effectué dans un cadre assez
spécifique la vitesse de la fusée est
constante puis ont fait demi-tour quasi
instantanément et on revient avec la
vitesse opposés mais on peut
complètement généraliser à d'autres
mouvements
si on regarde le diagramme
d'espace-temps on l'a dit les jumeaux
suivent deux trajectoires différentes
qui relie deux événements la séparation
et les retrouvailles mais on peut
imaginer tout un tas d'autres
trajectoires avec des vitesses et des
accélérations variable qui relie ces
deux points l'espace temps et à chacun
de ces trajets correspond un temps
propre différents pour des trajectoires
très accéléré il pourra même être aussi
petit qu'on veut mais dans tous les cas
la trajectoire inertielle celle du
jumeau terrestre sera toujours celle qui
fournit le temps propre le plus élevé on
dit qu'elle maximise le temps propre
un peu comme à l'opposé dans l'espace
sur une carte la ligne droite est
toujours le chemin qui minimisent la
distance d'un lieu à un autre
le fait que le principe de calcul du
temps propre se généralise à d'autres
mouvements et d'ailleurs ce qui a permis
de tester le paradoxe des jumeaux dans
une véritable expérience avec des
horloges
[Musique]
revenons en 1971 à cette époque le débat
sur la question n'est pas encore
totalement terminée il y a toujours
quelques physiciens qui ne crois pas à
cette histoire d'horloge qui ne
marquerait pas le même temps après avoir
suivi des chemins différents
alors deux physiciens américains à féret
et keating décide de faire vraiment
l'expérience évidemment ils ne vont pas
partir dans l'espace dans une fusée pour
un voyage de plusieurs années mais
simplement faire un tour de la terre en
avril
ce n'est pas exactement le même calcul
que la trajectoire en ligne droite du
jumeau la fusée mais les équations de la
relativité permettent sans problème de
traiter ce cas a fallu avec keating font
d'abord le calcul théorique où ils
estiment les quarts auxquels il faut
s'attendre si on fait voler une horloge
autour de la terre par rapport à une
horloge qui resterait au sol pour un
avion volant vers l'est ils prédisent
que l'horloge retardera de 49 secondes
et pour un avion volant vers l'ouest
elle avancera de 275 nano secondes
alors oui par rapport aux paradoxes des
jumeaux tel qu'on l'a présenté au début
il y a une différence à cause de la
rotation de la terre du fait que la
terre tourne au qu'une horloge n'est sur
une véritable trajectoire inertielle pas
même l'horloge de référence à celle qui
reste au sol
l'horloge qui veulent vers l'ouest va à
l'encontre de la rotation de la terre
donc elle est plus proche d'une vraie
trajectoire inertielle on s'attend donc
à ce que pour elle
l'écoulement du temps et était plus
important pour celle qui va vers l'est
est bien celle inverse et vous voyez que
les écarts calculé ne sont pas énormes
quelques centaines de nano secondes
maximum mais à l'époque les progrès des
horloges atomiques permettait d'espérer
une précision de l'ordre d'une dizaine
de nano secondes ce qui rendait possible
de tenter l'expérience
alors assez pour la théorie qu'on fait
appel keating pour tester cela eh bien
ils ont d'abord demandé un financement
de 8000 $ avec lequel ils ont acheté
huit billets d'avion pour faire le tour
du monde en plusieurs escales sur chaque
vol il y avait deux places pour eux et
deux places enregistré au nom d'un
certain mr clock
il s'agissait en fait de quatre rouges
atomique ils ont ainsi fait le parcours
une fois dans un sens et une fois dans
l'autre
et à chaque fois ils ont comparé sa avec
d horloge restée au sol et roulements de
tambour voici les écarts qu'ils ont
trouvée 59 nano secondes en moins
l'avion volant vers l'est et 273 nano
secondes en plus pour celui volant vers
l'ouest pour la première fois l'histoire
on faisait une vraie expérience de
paradoxes des jumeaux et on montrait le
phénomène avec des vrais horloge et donc
pour 8000 $ seulement ils ont quand même
réussi à tester l'une des prédictions
les plus importantes et les plus
spectaculaires de la théorie de la
relativité évidemment l'expérience de
apple keating a définitivement mis un
terme aux débats
et aujourd'hui tous les physiciens
reconnaissent bien que le décalage d
horloge est un phénomène réel selon
votre trajectoire votre temps propres
mesuré entre deux événements ne sera pas
le même alors comme souvent cet effet
très étonnant de la physique a inspiré
des oeuvres de fiction une qui est
intéressante c'est le roman de joe
haldeman forever war la guerre éternelle
en france est sorti en 1974
dans ce roman l'auteur imagine des
soldats envoyés à l'autre bout de la
galaxie à l'aide d'une nouvelle
technologie afin de combattre des
méchants aliens
l'histoire commence en 1997 dans le
roman et le héros retourne sur terre
après deux ans de combat
sauf que s'il ne s'est écoulé que deux
ans pour lui 27 ans ont passé sur terre
qui est maintenant en 2024
et oui à cause de la différence des
temps propres et donc notre héros
revient dans un monde et une société qui
ont complètement changé par rapport à ce
qu'il a connu et il a bien du mal à
s'adapter à cette nouvelle vie ensuite
il se passe plein d'autres trucs et ça
recommence même de façon encore plus
importante
ce qui est intéressant dans cette
histoire c'est que dans le roman cet
effet est utilisé comme une métaphore de
la guerre du vietnam et des difficultés
de réinsertion sociale qu'ont connu les
soldats américains à leur retour
ça avait été d'ailleurs le cas de joe
haldeman l'auteur une autre oeuvre de
fiction bien connu qui exploite le
paradoxe des jumeaux c'est évidemment le
film interstellar de christopher nolan
avec une légère variante toutefois
puisque dans l'intervalle à la
principale cause de décalage temporel
c'est le champ gravitationnel est oui
pour l'instant j'ai uniquement parler du
paradoxe des jumeaux dans le cadre de la
relativité restreinte sans la gravité
mais la prise en compte de celle ci
modifie légèrement la donne
plus précisément la théorie de la
relativité générale nous fait
interpréter la gravité comme une
déformation de l'espace temps et sans
rentrer dans les calculs géométriques
bourrin vous vous doutez que si je
déforme l'espace temps ça va changer les
calculs de temps et 10
ans c'est comme si sur une carte je
place soudainement une chaîne de
montagnes ça va modifier les distances à
parcourir pour aller d'un point à un
autre et bien en relativité générale le
temps propre le long d'une trajectoire
va dépendre de la courbure de l'espace
temps qu'on va traverser
mais attention ça fonctionne à nouveau à
l'envers de l'intuition de la carte
géographique les zones de l'espace temps
très court b vont donner lieu à des
temps propres plus faible
et d'ailleurs c'est surtout la courbure
du temps qui provoque cet effet et donc
si deux jumeaux sépare que l'un va vivre
dans une zone de plus forte gravité
disons proche d'un trou noir et revient
ensuite voir l'autre celui qui aura à
voyager près du trou noir aura moins
vieilli alors deux choses à ce sujet je
les occulter tout à l'heure mais dans
l'expérience de apple et keating avec
les avions cet effet de gravité jouait
aussi un rôle
le vol des avions se produit en altitude
donc dans un champ de gravité plus
faible qu'à la surface de la terre
ça a bien sûr été pris en compte dans le
calcul l'autre chose c'est que cet effet
gravitationnel on a aussi pu le tester
expérimentalement indépendamment de
l'effet cinématiques en 2010 dans un
article publié dans science
des physiciens ont montré qu'ils avaient
mesurer le décalage de temps propre
entre deux horloges qui étaient espacés
de seulement 33 cm de hauteur
comme cette très légère différence
d'altitude induit une très légère
diminution du champ gravitationnel
l'horloge situé en bas a subi une
courbure plus importante et donc à moins
vieilli que celle du groupe est noté que
dans la version général de l'hfr avec la
gravité
on retrouve la même idée que dans la
version en relativité restreinte
c'est la trajectoire inertielle qui
maximise le temps propre
or en relativité générale la trajectoire
inertielle ça n'est plus la trajectoire
rectiligne uniforme c'est la chute libre
donc si vous prenez deux points de
l'espace temps c'est la trajectoire de
chute libre qui les relient qui semblera
la plus longue alors ça une conséquence
amusante si vous tombez dans un trou
noir
mieux vaut ne pas se débattre une fois
passé l'horizon votre destin est de
toute façon figé vous allez finir dans
la singularité du trou noir
alors autant profiter au maximum de la
descente en maximisant sont en propre et
pour ça il faut suivre la trajectoire
inertielle se laisser tomber
si vous vous acharnez a essayé de
ressortir en allumant des moteurs ou
quoi que ce soit d'une part ça ne
servira à rien
et en plus ça diminuera votre temps
propre jusqu'à la singularité
vous vivrez moins longtemps et donc le
conseil tourisme du jour si vous tombez
dans un trou noir laissez vous faire et
profiter du temps qui vous reste voilà
c'est tout pour aujourd'hui j'espère que
cette vidéo on vous aura permis d'y voir
un tout petit peu de plaire sur cet
apparent paradoxe est sur la bonne
manière de le traiter dans le cadre de
la relativité
les actus de la chaîne c'est sur
facebook et sur twitter abonnés ou la
cloche tout ça et on se retrouve
prochainement pour une nouvelle vidéo
à bientôt
[Musique]